ich will euch nicht sagen aber irgendwie
sehen die alle die selber bisschen
komisch aus gestern ging germany's next
topmodel 2021 los und ich habe es
natürlich verschlafen irgendwann so um
circa 22.30 hat mir dann eines der ca
4000 models mit denen ich täglich am
schreiben bin geschrieben ich gucke gntm
was machst du so ich mich dann also vor
den fernseher gesetzt meine
fernbedienung genommen erst mal
realisiert verdammt ich per gar kein
fernsehen doch dann habe ich
herausgefunden dass es für die mtm auch
einen live stream gibt und er lief
ziemlich beschissen
jetzt habe ich mich dann einfach mal
angemeldet und habe mir das angeguckt
und hat zum bisschen was gefehlt für
meine in story zum beispiel eine
kandidatin die war richtig schlau
unterwegs
sonst wird die schau auch einfach
unendlich lang gehen wenn man allerdings
gntm sagt muss man natürlich auch heidi
klum sagen bzw heidi hans und franz so
wurden in der sendung einfach ihre
beiden melonen genannt ja ich habe auch
namen ferrari hat sich übrigens auch
während der show etwa dreimal umgezogen
und sie hatte jedes mal einfach weniger
an und das war wie generell sollen
dingen bei der ersten folge von gntm
2021 die wollten einfach nackte haut
sehen und ich denke einfach nur so ey
jahr 2021 ich glaube die können selbst
entscheiden was die da preisgeben wollen
und was nicht
das hat nämlich diese person hier anders
gesehen ich weiß nicht wie er heißt aber
er war ziemlich creepy der typ hat
nämlich locker alle 20 sekunden sein
handy raus golfer die mädels gefilmt
oder sowie heidi sagen würde mädchen wo
gibts eigentlich diesen coolen pop
sockel und falls ihr euch übrigens
fragen sollte warum dieser star juror so
komisch aussah hat manfred r imakler ist
eine optische veränderung einem unfall
in einem fitnessstudio geschuldet bei
dem sein gesicht zertrümmert wurde wie
er dem magazin
erzählte danach legte er sich mehrfach
unters messer seine nase sieht nun viel
breiter aus als früher und sein gesicht
wird stahl sein ziel sei es nun wie eine
statue aus zu sehen
ja unser boy manfred will wie eine
statue aussehen
das ist die nächste sache alter die
haben immer so eine geile musik gntm
dass ich zu hause einfach mit gewalt
habe für mich war dass das club ereignis
der letzten zwölf monate
es ist schon ziemlich traurig weil es
einfach nur 20 sekunden ausschnitt eines
videos bei germany's next topmodel
die hatten natürlich auch wieder
komische outfits an doch dann ging es
los
also dann war es vorbei weil also ich
hab ich habe ziemlich spät eingeschaltet
aber dann ging es los mit der
entscheidung wer rausfliegt
auch seien richtig um einbrecher werbe
sorry an alle franziska so ihr seid
bestimmt ganz ganz nette tolle
herzlicher und die besten menschen der
welt allerdings muss ich bei franziska
immer unseren mädchen denken die einen
erstens nie abschreiben lassen zweitens
wenn man einen vertretungslehrer hat und
er ist nicht gekommen sind die franziska
zimmer ins leere laufen dann bescheid
gesagt und franziska haben immer den
lehrer an die hausaufgaben erinnert
diese drei sachen zusammen franziska
leider du glaub ich eher als ganz blöd
track ist leider raus gewartet wurde in
der ersten folge
und jetzt weiter freuen ich habe mir
diese szene wirklich 20 mal angeguckt
und ich kann nicht ich kann wirklich
immer noch nicht sagen was sie da gesagt
hat und jetzt weiter frisch freuen
oder soll man sich für den fisch freund
nicht alle mitnehmen fängt es mir leid
die reise ja alexander ist rausgeflogen
und dann war dann das fenster noch der
moment wo für mich dann wirklich da war
es dann vorbei
habe ich mich um andere dinge gekümmert
wo es bist du mehr
wir sind einfach die nürnberger es war
dann wird ein anderes mädchen irgendwie
gezeigt die da eine zusage von heidi
bekommen hat dass sie in die nächste
runde ist das richtig gut er kann
[Musik]
höchstwahrscheinlich also normalerweise
ist es bei gntm so dass wenn du weiter
kommt dass du dann auch 100 prozent
weiter bist doch jetzt kommen wir zu
einer richtig krassen entscheidung und
ich habe irgendwie den falschen filter
glaube ich ausgewählt für den moment
habe ich vielleicht bei einer extrem
wichtigen entscheidungen party filter
genommen
also ich will mich da jetzt nicht allzu
weit aus dem fenster lehnen weil ich
selber jetzt persönlich noch nie bei
gntm dabei war
ich glaube allerdings dass wenn man bei
gntm dabei ist die chance schon circa
bei 100 prozent stehen dass heidi mit
einem redet also ist nur eine vermutung
quatsch vanessa wir glauben an dich
die show muss weitergehen
man kann auch wirklich eigentlich mal so
ein bingo daraus machen welche top fünf
sachen kommen jeder gntm folge vor also
erstens auf jeden fall dass eine person
hoyle zweitens dass heidi sagt es kann
nur eine germany's next topmodel werden
drittens dass eine werbung kommt die so
vor der entscheidung kommt und weiter
ist der neue volvo xc gehaltene pampers
werbung
[Musik]
das halt wirklich so ein ding das sind
immer diese werbungen nach diesem spot
geht es weiter oder dieses haye noch ein
spot und dann geht es weiter mit
germany's next topmodel kommt noch 200
weitere werbung
ja aber zeit für vier stunden werbung er
drei stunden folge es drin das schwerste
ist dass ich nicht mehr dabei sein kann
sondern dass sich die mädels nur lassen
muss und nicht mehr teil ihrer reise
sein kann das genauso wie ein fußballer
nach einem tor sagen ich bin einfach so
froh dass ich mit meinem tor der
mannschaft helfen konnte nur einfach und
sagt einfach das war eine geile bude
machen freut euch für mich bevor wir es
vergessen übrigens robbie williams war
auch mit dabei
ja und dann war es vorbei ist mir
aufgefallen dass solche sendungen wie
gntm afonso 70.000 firmen präsentiert
wird in dem fall jetzt peppers
präsentiert die im volvo präsentiert
ihren tier im flakon nie ich meine frau
die macht noch sinn aber pampers
nächstes jahr wird dann gntm 2022
präsentiert vom ja weiter die freude
damit würde ich jetzt meine reaction auf
die erste episode von gntm 2021 jetzt
auch beenden bitte versteht dass keine
kommentare von mir selbstverständlich
irgendwie beleidigend gemeint sein
sollen ich möchte keine person mehr
angreifen ich liebe die mtm aber ich
liebe es auch nicht ein bisschen darüber
lustig zu machen wird alles als ironie
an
ich bin kein beleidigender mensch bin
nur beleidigt wenn wir wieder hier in
eis geliefert wird was ich mir bestellt
hat was dann aber mit mit links drin war
wer macht er es in seiner sonja auch
dass ich nicht richtig auf die mtm
reagieren konnte von wegen wir schauen
uns die folge zusammen haben und so
weiter und so fort habe ich leider nicht
die rechte daran
gntm hast mich seit mein reschen den
letzten jahren wo ich ja nie sonderlich
nett war deswegen sind jetzt weg
gegangen über instagram und ihr könnt
auch unserem video müsste aber nicht
konnte aber müsste aber nicht aber könnt
ihr nicht